[Music]
hello and welcome to quadriga DWS
international talk show coming to you
from Berlin I'm Brian Thomas there's
been a seismic political shift in Turkey
where the opposition CHP party has won
the vote for mayor in Turkey's biggest
city and financial capital Istanbul this
man
Akram M Imola has called his victory a
new beginning for the country one of his
fellow party leader says it is now time
to end President Aaron's quote one-man
regime and build a democratic system
days after the vote air Dhawan himself
promised to draw lessons from it saying
he understood the messages given by the
people Turkey is air Diwan losing his
grip that's our topic here on quadri
gonna talk about that I'm joined here in
the studio by shadi Oates Damir he works
for DWS Turkish Department and says a
great moment for Turkish democracy but
the real struggle has only begun Allen
Posner is a commentator for the day LED
belt he believes air Diwan has lost the
trust of the educated lease but he is
far from finished and Laura Lala kvass
is an analyst for Turkish politics for
the Berlin based think tank German
Council on Foreign Relations she thinks
quote the result of the local election
since us full and other metropolitan
cities indicate a shift in political
conditions in Turkey
well thanks to all of you for being here
and thanks to our viewers from wherever
you are as well Laura if we could start
with you
what's happening in Turkey and what are
the voters in Istanbul saying right now
well I think what we've seen in the
municipal elections not just in Istanbul
but also already in March is that the
AKP is losing its grip especially in the
big cities in Turkey the cities that you
know obviously have regular population
there are the economic centers of Turkey
and Istanbul especially obviously was
you know really important for the
opposition to win before the AKP
obviously a very hurtful loss and I
think what we see is that first of all
the opposition
which is
different fractions of people actually
could unite around this idea of saying
you know kind of like we are united
against the system for against this like
one-man regime at the same time we also
see that you know more and more
supporters of the AKP in the mayor happy
coalition actually disappointed in the
government and also themselves not
turning out to vote as much as they did
before maybe some shifted disappoints
the disappointment in the AKP might be
an understatement
Charlotte what do you think triggered
this result I think it has multiple
factors obviously and economy conditions
has always been one of the dominant
forces economies very big and and and in
Turkey if we look at the breaking points
when it when were talking about the
similar seismic shifts in the political
environment in Turkey over the past 50
years we always see the economy as one
of the most important underlying causes
of that so when the public when when the
people on the street are having a
problem with take bringing the bread at
home they are looking for alternatives
and like this course might be a good
driving force or other political factors
might be good good driving forces but at
the end of the day economics and and the
way that people can make an earning
makes a decision and I think one of the
main reasons why people decided to jump
off the boat right now is because of the
political economic situation in the
country economics is so determined in a
vote especially one like this for a city
like Istanbul for big cities Allen when
you look at this is it just the
economics of the background to this vote
or is it also aired on potentially
losing his political instincts I mean
he's the one who called for this rerun
vote right and that was a huge mistake
because the first time his party lost I
think by thirteen thousand votes now
they lost by eight hundred yeah a teeth
out there i'm een in cry
and people you know put off the holidays
to be there and to be able to vote or
came back from their holidays or from
from from wherever they were to vote
against other one so this is this is a
huge huge huge miscalculation and and so
people with but in spite of this if you
look at the map of survey IDI the the
sort of election map of Turkey and you
say that the CHP is red you got a red
rim the part of Turkey that tourists see
you know assemble Izmir down there
Antalya and so and they're all there
were Western looking people educated
people people have to do with tourism
are situated they voted against add-on
but the huge inside except for Ankara is
still power base I mean where the the
rural areas you know the poor parts of
the country the religious parts of the
country people were Sunni religious is
very strong they still vote for the AKP
and and unless you can bridge that gap
turkeys gonna fall apart as it has so
often before we're going to talk about
bridging that gap and that divide coming
up in in the program I'd like to go back
to Laura and what you were saying about
the AKP
there is talk right now of a split in
the governing party in the AKP do you
think that's a possibility well I mean
rooms have been going on for quite a
while now that's you know prominent
figures within the AKP like Ali Baba
John or you know devil total and after
law school are considering forming their
own movements that when party of
splitting away from the AKP and I think
you know if that's the case if we will
see that the election has made that
probably more likely that they will see
this like as an opportunity now to like
kind of move forward with with such
ambitions and there has been a you know
kind of differences in opinion within
the AKP for quite a while and we've seen
much more criticism coming out of out of
the AKP itself Charro's do you think
that is something everyone's struggling
with right now keeping the party
together I totally agree with this point
of view because Ireland has already been
losing the people that he started his
own cause of it when he formed the AKP
back in the
beginning of 2000's so the figures like
Alibaba John opted lucky I made turbo
told blend arranged and so on and so
forth these figures were belonging to
their cause at that cause was kind of
actually bringing together the
conservative masses with the central
right leaning people in Turkey and the
AKP has always been a coalition of
different center-right forces or
sometimes to an extreme right but those
forces in Turkey so its base never
represented as some sort of a political
Islam that is being depicted all the
time and once that coalition starts to
shatter and I'm where I want to go back
to the economy and economy what is one
of the reasons why it would shatter then
you might start seeing those movements
coming within from within the party and
if you if you add the fact that Ireland
has managed to antagonize the people
that he started with and he surrounded
himself with a bunch of yes-man over the
past few years then he started losing
his grip so it actually now based his
the whole party is based on his charisma
and nothing else because they are not
producing in a sort of policies over the
past five years okay so you're saying
there is a possibility that he could
lose his grip on power would that mean
from what I'm hearing is there's a
possibility that he could be replaced by
a broader conservative coalition would
that get a majority in the country I
don't think so and I don't think he
would lose his grip within his own party
but his own party eventually might lose
its grip over the over the government so
like you know if we go to an election
sometime soon it's not going to happen
before 2022 - at least on this there's a
early election called
then the AKP might not be able to secure
a majority within the Parliament but
that's far ahead but I think I think we
should focus on right now how his party
will manage to survive this all yeah
that's experiencing right now that's
related to the vote and the economy well
there is a consensus right now that this
vote was free and fair and as Alan was
pointing out it's also pointed out that
there's a deep divide in Turkish society
between conservative voters mainly in
the countryside and the
more liberal voters in urban areas I'm
so excited
the right person has won justice has won
love and unity one the people in
Istanbul have won everything is great
now we will work for a brighter future
together shoulder to shoulder really I'm
so happy
change was necessary people had enough
of the incumbent government turkey needs
fresh blood new rhetoric and a new face
I think this result is a reflection of
that I think people don't see the good
things tie affair to one has done we're
all said our relatives came here from
other cities just for today no we're so
disappointed the government mustn't
allow him to serve his mayor okay we
just heard one AKP voter they're saying
the government should step in and
overturn the popular vote that was the
last soundbite we listen to how deeper
the divisions between AKP voters and the
opposition shot up I think the way that
the government has been playing this
whole blame game over the past few years
because of the negativity negative
things going on in the country that has
a resonance within within the you know
party supporters within the masses but I
think that resonance is no longer as
valid as it used to be so of course
there's this polarization of course
there's this divide within the society
and I think what a cream Imam all the
did just for the municipality but it's a
big discourse and that discourse is
based on not polarization but having a
comprehensive approach trying to reach
out to everyone and I think it turned
out to be a good strategy because we're
seeing that like they from a few
thousand watts we have hundreds of
thousands of what difference in just
three weeks later that means that there
is a huge shift from the AKP from the
people who voted for the AKP candidate
and then shifted to Imam all so turkey
is actually very tired of this polarized
language there were eight election
in the country over the past six years
can you imagine that almost one election
including local elections and
referendums so people are tired of
elections and you cannot do business
when you're in a election environment we
were waiting for what's gonna happen
after the elections and as you are tired
from that kind of a environment and as
you're tired from that kind of a
political division and polarization then
you start shifting to a person who's
giving you hope and even want to manage
to actually gather the hope of so many
people and I think is gonna be over time
more successful as he will continue
playing this game because they managed
to find a good strategy and they are
developing them and there it's just the
beginning for them but it's gonna be a
long and hard way to go and challenge
the government itself Allen when you
hear about this type of political
strategy do you think it could be a
winner to bring a country together you
know I I really don't know know enough
about CHP and and Emmylou to to to judge
that but all I'm saying is everyone
anticipated this this is why he changed
the system so we now have a presidential
system if he was just you know Prime
Minister or of Turkey in like in like
Theresa May in Britain you know he could
you know he might be out tomorrow but as
a president he's in also don't forget
that you know there are hundreds if not
thousands of journalists in jail of
teachers of people accused of being
members of the Gulen sect and before
that there are some people in jail who
he together with Gulen he got rid of out
of the military and so on so he does he
I mean I really wouldn't underestimate
Godwin's power he may have lost the mass
of people in in in Istanbul and Ankara
and Izmir but he has as long as the
military is still behind him when he's
purged the military as long as he's the
president you know I the question is can
a mamola and the CHP and the opposition
keep up this momentum but across the
country the real question should be like
in Turkey potentially would power shift
hands in a peaceful transformation I
think that should be the question that
needs to be asked because as
said and you're right in that the whole
system is now structured in a way that
our dog keeps his grip over the country
which is very less stable in fact it is
less stable politically economically
internationally it is less stable but at
the same time as I was saying the whole
system is actually kind of keeping him
as in power and this like like I was
trying to say earlier turkey the Turkish
government did not develop a viable
policy a policy that a state needs to
address to the needs of its population
in the past five six years so the whole
system is based actually designed
actually upon keeping a personality on
power and that is one of the weakest
point but at the same time that is one
of the strongest point of the opposition
not to be and not to be underestimated
either I mean that's at the same time a
house of cards it's a house of cards but
we have to look at this base that that
Ellen pointed out is strongly behind
air21 I mean when you when you look at
the numbers 45% of Istanbul voted
against mmm Oh Lu I mean that that's an
important point in and for the AKP
Skanda d't how do they view Laura where
they want the country headed this 45% in
Istanbul not in the conservative areas
out in the countryside where do they
want to see the country headed well I
think first of all I would say you know
Istanbul also has very conservative area
so it wouldn't kind of make this
distinction just like say it's the
liberal Istanbul and the conservative
course is light yeah and I think so I
think for for lots of people that are
still the belief in the president and
that our lawn can deliver they there's a
belief that's you know for them this is
still the right direction even if it's
not perfect but it's still the best
option compared to the GRP or other
parts for the opposition parties so I
think obviously you know the the support
for add-on or the AKP isn't going to go
away in like a day and I think a lot of
people still also think at the times
where the AKP really did develop the
economy really well they look at you
know the improvements I have been made
to Istanbul
and so I think it's a question of you
know kind of where do they see the
future but also kind of do they
who do they believe can deliver you know
a solution to the problems and who is a
better alternative sure you have an
economic analysis here you think
political Islam is secondary to how the
economy is going but what do the
conservative voters what did what does
the base for erawan want to see for the
nation what are their interests what are
their goals in reference to my words
earlier like the AKP has always been a
coalition of different forces within the
society not necessarily coming from a
very conservative background more a
political Islamist worldview
so those center-right forces have come
together and the AKP managed to deliver
within the first decade what they were
looking for they were looking for more
representation they were looking for
more opportunities in economic ways and
we've seen this huge boom within the in
the countryside in Anatolia that new
entrepreneurs came out new holdings were
formed new companies started so the AKP
managed to create its own kind of a
middle-class base at which people are
enjoying the things that modern
capitalism can deliver in their own way
so this is still valid and I think one
of the reasons why they the government
party still has almost half of the
support within the society is because we
have never directory because they
delivered that but at the same time they
are failing more and more day by day to
debt continue delivering that so that's
why it might shift the power might shift
okay let's talk about the possible power
shift who is the man that millions of
people in Turkey are pinning their hopes
on Akram and mamola let's find out Akram
Imam Oulu addresses his supporters he
presents a young and dynamic image his
slogan is everything will be fine the 49
year old has managed to present himself
as worldly and open yet conservative and
religious to his style contrasts with
the authoritarianism of president regi
up tie of heir to one
the central left candidate of the
Republican People's Party managed to
garner votes from many kurds and a kay
party supporters as well he presents
himself as someone who wants to and can
unite the people not a victory this is a
new beginning I would like to say that
as of tomorrow as mayor I will treat 16
million people equally the mayor's
office and Istanbul is said to be the
key to the office of the presidency of
turkey could Imam Oulu pose a threat to
air Dewan Allen what do you think
ken he posed a threat to air - one can
he bring the nation together behind his
leadership I think if he can form a
coalition with with the liberal elements
who supported the AKP or work part of
the AKP he must reach out to the more
religious parts of society then if you
can do that great job I agree with that
I think so far he has been playing the
game right and if he doesn't fail in his
game and if he continues gathering the
masses behind him get yet gets the
support then he might eventually
challenge the leadership in the country
what do you think Laura is he ready for
national politics well I think you know
I agree in that I think he has been
playing that really well right now
the question is can he actually keep
that up because at the moment he's
trying to unify the more conservative as
well as the Nationalists as well as the
Kurdish as well as the secular liberals
so you know I think the question is can
he keep keep that up what he has been
doing right now really successfully well
jailing political opponents is one
method the Aird want government has used
as it sees it to guarantee national
unity well at points of the country's
failed coup the Kurdish separatist
movement and the ongoing violence in
Syria as threats to national unity air21
points of the country's failed to as the
primary element there but as critics say
he's using these very real challenges as
excuses to crack down on people who do
not share
his vision of where turkey should go
sixteen of them are in court right now
for what's known as the gays a trial
they're some of the many thousands
who've been jailed for their political
leanings the C Libre Court and prison
complex west of Istanbul is said to be
the biggest of its kind in Europe the
court rooms are mainly for political
trials sixteen representatives of
turkey's civil society are in the dock
lawyers architects and artists accused
of planning and financing an attempt to
oust air 2 on their protests began
peacefully in 2013 they were primarily
directed against plans to build on the
site of Ghazi park in Istanbul yet
allegations of corruption and nepotism
and president air diwan's government
grew louder and louder the more violence
the police and state used against the
demonstrators the more nearby residents
supported the protests demonstrations
took place in other Turkish cities as
well people were killed and wounded when
air21 ultimately had Daisy Park cleared
in June 2013
back then err Dhawan was already putting
the blame on a terrorist conspiracy with
financial backing from abroad while his
supporters hailed him as a hero
how stable is heir to one's government
now when we talk about stability for the
air21 government we also have to talk
about the international picture Turkey's
having a lot of problems right now with
the United States United States is
threatening sanctions against Turkey can
air to one shot afford to shift as he is
right now
towards Russia buying the s400 missile
system and risk his relations with the
West I think this question has two
answers one of them is that Arizona has
been playing sporadically this game by
trying to align with the antagonists of
the West and get some reaction to it and
then playing into that in a way that he
would gather the actual support that
he's looking for so it's kind of like a
leverage game for him if I may put it
that way so it has been tried in the
past and it worked to an extent
sometimes it doesn't so one answer is
that if he keeps content if he keeps
playing this game he might eventually
lose all the support that's coming from
the West so that's one thing but the
other thing is that he should not
underestimate and I'm sure he doesn't
underestimate the fact that the boom the
economic boom that Turkey went through
over the past 15 years was thanks to
mostly foreign direct investment that
came to turn the west and that was
mainly from the West and that yeah if we
weren't comfortable that is some sort of
important factors that turkey should
consider at the moment because that
money kind of dried out now Allen why
would erawan risk relations with the
West at a time when he's experiencing so
many domestic challenges we look at the
vote in Istanbul by buying the Russian
s400 anti-missile system well I'll tell
you why because we let him down because
we lost Syria because when the West said
that you know precondition we wanted to
get rid of the regime in
and we would do that by supporting the
opposition everyone went fully for that
game and demanded that Assad be removed
now he's we the West lost to Russia and
Iran who are proxies of China in Syria
now if I were at one I would be hedging
my bets which is exactly what he's doing
he's not sure who's going to be the
dominant power in the region in five or
ten years because America seems
disengaged in Europe is busy chewing up
itself so you know we we need to get our
act together if we want add-on to be on
our side it's really up to us Laura we
saw there the gays a trial the
suppression of opposition voices there's
a number out there hundred forty
thousand people one hundred forty
thousand people have been arrested um
are you worried about a crackdown
domestically a further crackdown when
you look at a turkey today after this
vote as a possible response to the CAHPS
victory well I think the correct term
has been going on Quinn system
continuously so and I don't expect it to
go down I don't expect it to die down in
any way you know we've just seen it like
the start of the gezi is it trials you
know there was this threat that you know
he might you know that in my model might
get you know sued for for insulting so
on so I say I don't think that this is
going to die down I don't think we're
going to see like a kind of a speak in
crackdowns all of a sudden again but I
definitely don't think that it's gonna
go down Chara what do you think I think
I agree with her and at the same time I
think this gezi trial has a symbolic
value because gezi for many people in
Turkey including the government circles
was when the downturn started for the
government so like I was saying see Oh
since gezi
the government did not produce a viable
policy okay for Turkey and we'll see if
they'll come up with one now I'd like to
thank all of our guests for coming in
today thank you so very much and our
viewers for joining us of course as well
for me Brian Thomas and the entire
quadriga team take care until next time
[Music]